hi everybody um i hope that you can all
hear me
i am liz makowski at unc chapel hill i'm
an assistant professor in the department
of nutrition
and today i'm going to talk about
obesity weight loss and the micro
environment in basal-like cancer basal
like breast cancer and i just want to
welcome you to type in your questions
and i'll read them out at the end and
answer as many questions as i can
and i also want to mention that this is
a cme accredited talk so there should be
a little button on your screen that if
you want to get credit for this you can
do that also
so
many people study the genetics of cancer
but today i'm going to talk about some
non-genetic contributing factors and
what i'm going to specifically speak
about is the role of diet and obesity in
breast cancer
so we know that obesity is a major
problem in the united states
um and if you look at this little map
the um
this shows the prevalence of obesity and
obesity is measured by bmi being
body mass index greater than 30. so if
you look at the darker colors that means
there's a high percentage of the us that
is obese
and
we know that there are many
complications of obesity and in my lab
we study diabetes heart disease and
breast cancer
so
the major take-home point i want you to
remember from today is that obesity is a
modifiable
risk factor for breast cancer
so why do i study breast cancer my
background is in obesity and macrophage
biology and
inflammation but it's really interesting
that obesity
is very similar to um some of the
effects we see
that might cause breast cancer because
the breast is also a big fat pad we see
very similar
effects
so what i'm going to talk about today is
a collaboration between myself and
melissa troster also here at unc and a
project that we have funded by the nci
and niehs called pregnancy obesogenic
environments and basal like breast
cancer and then at the end i'm going to
talk a little bit about our work in
collaboration with our community
partners through the center for
environmental health and susceptibility
so um
what we're interested in is our
hypothesis is that there's different
windows of susceptibility
so
throughout lifetime there are different
periods of the life when a woman might
be more susceptible to risk factors that
can cause breast cancer
so
the area that we focus on is the adult
period and the postpartum period where
we have normal tissue remodeling and
where we look at the effects of obesity
and also the contribution of the micro
environment so i'll get into what that
means
so we know that breast cancer is the
number one diagnosed breast cancer in
women and the second killer of women so
this is the huge problem and we need to
find
risk factors and modifiable risk factors
to prevent it we also know that this is
a huge problem worldwide
so as i mentioned when i started many
people look at genetic factors that
cause breast cancer and we know that
family history or genetic risk factors
can account for about five to fifteen
percent of breast cancer especially the
breast cancer genes like graca one and
bracket two
but that means that about eighty five
percent of breast cancer is not related
to family history so why is that
so there's lots of other risk factors
being a woman getting older
race and ethnicity your reproductive
history
lifestyle as i'll talk about today
environment and then known risk factors
like radiation so today i'm going to
talk about something that we do at unc
as part of our
breast cancer and the environment
research program or the bee serp
we're going to focus on race and
ethnicity reproductive history and
obesity
so what do i mean by weight and obesity
so when you talk about obesity we need
to consider the type and the timing or
the windows of obesity
so is there a weight change from
adolescent to adulthood or from early
adulthood late adulthood
can we categorize by pre-menopausal
obesity or post-menopausal obesity
because after menopause the estrogens
decrease
ovaries decrease estrogen production and
we could get estrogen production from
adipose tissue
so we need to really consider the
different types of obesity and when
obesity might affect risk
and the other thing we really need to
think about is considering different
subtypes of breast cancer
so what do i mean by breast cancer
subtypes
so when you get
a diagnosis of breast cancer a biopsy is
taken and immune histochemistry is
performed and that looks at different
proteins in your biopsy the estrogen
receptor progesterone receptor or the
her2 neu
epidermal growth factor so this can help
categorize the type
some type of breast cancer you have
and
certain treatments you may get
but then about 15 years ago chuck peru
who's also at unc
has defined something called breast
cancer intrinsic subtypes so these are
subtypes defined by gene expression not
protein expression so using microarrays
about 15 years ago
chuck looked at he was able to group
different breast cancers and they
grouped in different subtypes there's
about five subtypes represented
and these have been studied intensively
over the past years and the one i'm
highlighting with the arrow is basil
like breast cancer that's what i'm going
to talk about today
so let me just quickly review a little
bit about the mammary gland in the milk
duct because some of the terminology
comes from
the types of cells
so if we look at the mammary gland
we can see that there's luminal cells
here i'm putting some arrows near that
and then my epithelial cells and then we
have um some of these are called basal
myoepithelial cells so the milk is
secreted out this way and these basal
myoepithelial cells actually can help
push the milk out so they kind of have a
myocyte can have a myosite phenotype
also
so let's get back to the subtypes if we
look at the subtypes they're categorized
as
luminal a
luminal b
her2 or unclassified and you could see
if you look at the pie chart luminal a
actually comprises 44 percent of all
breast cancers so that's a large
percentage and a lot of times even in
the breast cancer field when you see a
talk people just say breast cancer in
general and that's
just statistically referring to luminal
a just because there's more
prevalence of luminal a
but what i'm going to talk about today
is basil like breast cancer
please we see that highlighted in gold
there's it's er negative pr negative and
her2 negative
so
basil like breast cancer is known as a
triple negative hormone receptor
cancer what that means is that there's
no specific drug therapies
it's known to be highly
high grade cancer aggressive with poor
survival there's a short survival time
after metastases
it's very prevalent in young women and
also in african americans
and the etiology remains unknown
and that's why we're investigating this
particular subtype
and what's really interesting is that
obesity
is a risk factor for both pre and
post-menopausal
basal like breast cancer so i'm going to
get into that in a little bit more
detail
so breast cancer has complex
relationships with obesity if we look at
epidemiological data we see that
some early early studies showed that
obesity does not
i'm highlighting does not increase
breast cancer risk in pre-menopausal
women
but obesity did increase
breast cancer risk in post-menopausal
women
but this was before we had um careful
categorization of subtypes and again
more recently
showed weight gain affects breast cancer
and postmenopausal women so for a long
time people thought that premenopausal
obesity was not a major concern
but until the carolina breast cancer
study and some other studies have
have looked very carefully and over
sampled minorities we now see that
there's very different relationship with
obesity in basal like breast cancer
so
when we look at some data from
millikin's paper when we're categorized
in luminal a
and basal-like we see that the
waist-to-hip ratio
with an increased weight slip ratio we
see higher odds ratio for risk of
basal-like breast
cancer so this means and other studies
have also shown that obesity measured by
bmi is associated with risk in young
premenopausal women
but didn't have effects on aluminum so
again we see different effects on
breast cancer depending on when obesity
is
is prevalent
so
there's a lot of misconceptions
premenopausal obesity has no effect or
slightly decreased risk of breast cancer
so yes that statement is true if we
consider overall breast cancer which
again is mainly represented by luminal
because that's the most prevalent
subtype and it's most associated with
postmenopausal obesity but that
statement is false if we consider
premenopausal obesity and postmenopausal
for basal like breast cancer so we need
to remember that basal breast cancer is
associated with obesity before and after
if we turn to mouse models
there's lots of studies out there
showing that obesity can increase breast
cancer
or tumor genesis but most of these
have are luminal a type models
prior to our recent work there have been
no studies examining the effects of
obesity
on basal like breast cancer using
genetically engineered mouse models
so we turned to mouse models to look at
obesity and breast cancer and again
chuck peru and hershkoitz did some
microarrays and actually compared human
tumors to
many different mouse models and we see
highlighted in red basal-like tumors and
one mouse model
co-localized very closely to the basal
like tumors and that's the c31 tag mouse
it's a so it's most it resembles
basal-like tumors in humans and i'll
tell you a little bit about the c3 tag
mice so this is a
t antigen expressing
transgenic mouse model so the t antigen
um blocks tumor suppressors to induce
tumor tumors it has characteristics of
basal like breast tumors brocco one
deficiency
p53 mutations or deficiency high
expression of certain keratins and peak
adherence
what's really important about this is
that the mice the mouse model has intact
stroma we don't need to do surgery or
xenografts or any kind of um clearing of
the fat pads we don't need any chemicals
or hormones to induce tumors
so 100 of mice get tumors so what we
want to look at is how obesity affects
breast cancer in this mouse model
and our hypothesis is that obesity can
reduce alterations that create a
permissive microenvironment
so if we look at this little model
between postnatal pubertal and
premenopausal adulthood period
and if we see this cartoon of the normal
mammary gland we see
changes or remodeling along and the dash
line indicates postpartum
remodeling
but with obesity
we propose that there's defects or
alterations in these um modifications
that happen over time
so perhaps there's sustained
modifications or remodeling of the
tissue
perhaps there's um
lots of modifications if you're obese
and puberty or later in life or early in
life
so
we wanted to model that in our mouse
model by looking at first adult windows
of susceptibility
we used our
c3 tag mice
and we
exposed these mice in adulthood after
puberty to either low-fat diet or
high-fat diet
these
mice gain weight and and we observe
tumor incidents
and after we see the tumor we palpate
for tumor and sacrifice after three
weeks
and along the way we characterize
metabolic parameters because we're
interested in obesity and other risk
factors we measure tumor outcomes and
then we focus on the normal memory gland
in tumors
so this work was published and i'm
focusing on my
postdoc sneha sunderland
and some of the other members of my lab
who helped contribute to this paper
so we showed that obesity or high fat
diet exposure can induce obesity we see
increases in body weight in the mice fed
the 60 diet
and doubling of fat mass my mri
and
our findings were that obesity blunted
latency so we saw a faster tumor onset
so in the red line looking at the tumor
free time um we see that there the
tumors in the high fat diet fed obese
mice came on sooner so there was a
shorter time to tumor
and we did not see changes in tumor
burden or tumor progression that were
significant
so just to summarize some data we saw no
changes in glucose
we saw no changes in insulin or homa no
changes in estrogen or progesterone in
the plasma we looked locally if there
were changes in aromatase in the mammary
gland and in fact we saw no aromatase at
all expression so
no aromatase in the memory
we did look at systemic inflammation and
local inflammation we did see a
significant increase in tnf alpha in the
plasma but no change in il-6 or mcp1
other commonly regulated
cytokines and chemo kinds of obesity
and then we looked locally using luminex
in the memory glands and tumors and saw
no changes locally
so this brings us back to the
environment and what is obesity doing so
this is a little cartoon modified from
vena bissell nina bissell was a pioneer
in the field looking at the role of the
microenvironment and if we look at this
little graph we see
on the y-axis barrier to cancer
formation and tumor genesis over time
and we see at the top how the
microenvironment can blunt or promote
tumor genesis so when we have a healthy
micro environment we're blunting
tumorogenesis but something switches
there's some barrier that gets um
crossed
and then we have a permissive
environment so then we kind of allow
tumor genesis to occur
so if we think back to the normal fat
pads
so in adipose tissue we know that
there's there's expansion of the adipose
tissue there could be
stress in the adipocytes hypoxia can
happen we could have inflammation
happening so lots of changes
and we've actually shown that
tumor
tumor
and stroma crosstalk is important in the
mammary gland
and some of the factors that we've
investigated are growth factors and
diplocoins that can be upregulated with
obesity that i'm listing here in our
little table but what i'm going to focus
on today is the role of fibroblasts in
this micro environment and specifically
the role of a growth factor called
hepatocyte growth factor
so
a lot of this work has been done in
collaboration with melissa troster who's
right here
my collaborator
in the epidemiology department at unc
she's done a lot of in ditra modeling of
human cell lines and human primary
samples
and so what they do is they look at
epithelial monocultures from luminal and
basal-like breast cancers and they also
look at fibroblasts in monoculture and
then what they do is direct co-culture
and they look at different mixes between
the fibroblasts
and luminal breast cancer cells or basal
like breast cancer cells
and what they've seen is dramatically
different patterns when you co-culture
fibroblasts with these different cell
lines so we see that basal like has a
very different pattern than aluminum
breast cancer cells
and so in many in many publications i've
indicated here
we and the truster lab have showed that
basal like breast cancer is
characterized by unique stromal
epithelial interactions
so
this is a little cartoon showing that um
if we look at
some epithelial
common epithelial cell line these are
called the mcf10a series so they
progress from normal epithelium
hyperplasia to ductal carcinoma in situ
and we see as these cells become
normal to more aggressive we see
increased
growth factor and this was published by
patricia casbass hernandez in the
truster lab
so um more work from our lab and others
has shown that the hdf hepatocyte growth
factor and its receptor cement are
important in basal like breast cancer
so in humans we have high expression of
cement which has correlated
significantly with basal like breast
cancer
and
in mouse models in basilic breast cancer
the cement locus is amplified
with elevated signaling
and the troster lab has also shown that
86 percent of basal like breast cancer
patients express an hgf signature so let
me just show you that data for a minute
this is from patricia casbass hernandez
in the truster lab and they looked at um
they
put the different tumor subtypes and the
hgs signature so what they found was
that basal-like tumors were very highly
positive for the hdf signatures whereas
the luminal um were not
and other subtypes were not so that
suggests that hgf cement signaling is
important in basal-like breast cancer
and then they correlated that with
survival so you see in basal tumors
on the left
that
the probability of survival was much
worse if the if the samples were hdf
positive if they expressed the signature
that was not true in other tumor
subtypes like luminal a that i'm showing
here
so this really speaks to the fact that
basil like breast cancer is specifically
potentially
the role of hdfc med is important in
basal like breast cancer so we wanted to
turn to our mouse models
and focus again on the normal micro
environment and also tumors
so again we look we used immune
histochemistry to look at hgfc med
in our
mouse models and we scanned our slides
with an imperial scanner that we have in
our lab and did quantitative analysis
and so we looked we confirmed that hdf
was indeed expressed in our fibroblasts
and less so in our tumors
and we looked at
the hdf cement pathway and then some of
the downstream effects
because this is a very carcinogenic
pathway
interestingly
it's involved in normal breast
remodeling throughout development but
also breast
carcinogenesis because it can perform
extra cellular matrix remodeling
induces growth induces motility
induces endogenesis and is
anti-apoptotic
so
our hypothesis is was that hcf cement
signaling could mediate epithelial
stromal communication during cancer
progression so indeed when we looked at
our cancer model we found that in mice
that were
in black the 10 percent fed or 60
the
obese mice we saw increases in hdf
expression with obesity
cement expression with obesity and
phospho-cnet so activation of cement
signaling in our normal mammary gland
in our normal mammary gland
um we also found
especially a
doubling of the cement receptor in
tumors
and so we wanted to then see at the time
we didn't have any tools to test the
hdfc pathway so we wanted to model in
vitro
some
using cells derived from our mice so we
were able to isolate mammary gland and
tumor and we
chopped up those tissues and isolated
fibroblasts so we isolated normal
associated fibroblasts and
cancer-associated fibroblasts so the
calves came from the tumors
and the navs came from the maori gland
and what we did with those is we
co-cultured them
we took our naps and our cats
and co-cultured them
um
and first well sorry before cold culture
we first looked at the media to see
what's what's happening with hgf so we
performed uh just simple eliza and
looked at um hdf secretion over time
and we saw that um
in our mice that were obese in the red
and in the mice that were in the
fibroblasts that were derived from
the tumors the caps we saw an elevation
of hdf secretion with obesity compared
to the lean and with cancer cells
compared to the normals
so our culture of pharmablast isolated
from obese mammaries and tumors secreted
more hgf
and then here's where we did the culture
um
we we first confirmed that um using
conditioned media that indeed that we
could see signaling of the cmet pathway
so if we looked at cm condition media
from our cells and a positive control of
recombinant mouse hdf we saw that we
could indeed induce possible statement
signaling
and then we looked at tumor cell
proliferation so we used a 4 t1
epithelial cancer cell line here
and we use conditioned media we have our
positive
and negative controls here we saw
induction of proliferation and when we
used conditioned media from our nassar
calves we saw that in the obese
the fibroblasts isolated from obese
tumors the cats
induce the most amount of proliferation
in our tumor cells
and then we want to see what happens
with proliferation and cell migration
and we use something called a scratch
test so this is where you create
basically a wound or
an area
for the cells to migrate into
so what we did was we fluorescently
labeled our cancer cell before t1 cancer
cells and we co-culture them with mass
and cats
and you could see
we looked at uh
we're going to look at hdf effects
specifically by using a blocking
antibody
so here's a
a picture we used um
microscopy and looked at the cells over
time and we just took a snapshot here to
show you and it's very detailed you
don't need to pay too much attention but
you could see the fluorescent cells
and then we use blocking antibodies in
the caps and the mats
and it's quantified in the next slide
so
when we look at the
amount of wound closure so how much did
the cells migrate into that center
and we see again just like proliferation
the most migration happened in
when fibroblasts were isolated from
obese tumors
and then interestingly when we used that
blocking antibody to block specifically
hdf function we saw a significant and
almost total blocking of this migration
um in the cancer-associated fibroblasts
from the obese mice we also saw it in
the lean mice in cancer-associated
fibroblasts so this suggests that hgf
was playing a specific role in causing
cancer
cancer cell
migration
so in summary for this part
we
demonstrated that obesity can lead to an
early basalic breast cancer onset so
that leads to an increased
aggressiveness of tumors in this
transgenic mouse model
hdf was shown to correlate with tumor
onset
we we saw increased hdf expression from
primary fibroblasts in an obesity
dependent way and fibroblasts isolated
from obese
mice and especially tumors from obese
mice dramatically regulated
proliferation and wound closure and we
showed that in an hdf-dependent way
so what what were our next steps so we
know that um obesity was causing the
effects but we were interested in ways
to either prevent obesity or reverse
obesity or possibly inhibit cement so
the world health organization has
indicated that body weight and physical
activity can account for
a fifth to a third of most of the common
cancers including breast cancer
and so a third of these cancers could be
avoided by eating healthy maintaining
normal weight and exercising and
the american society clinical oncologist
asco just put out a policy statement
saying that physicians need to pay more
attention to obesity and cancer
and there are epidemiological studies
supporting this there's plenty of
studies showing that either prevention
of weight gain or weight loss can
reduce breast cancer risk
um and again getting back to basal like
breast cancer the milliken paper
from the carolina breast cancer study
here at unc
um estimated i took this quote they
estimate up to 68 of basal like breast
cancer could be prevented by promoting
breastfeeding and by reducing abdominal
adiposity
so
weight loss
there are studies of weight loss in mice
many studies looking at caloric
restriction
energy balance intermittent caloric
restriction
and sen and many data looking at weight
loss basically demonstrate that weight
loss is also preventative for breast
cancer but none of these studies
examined weight loss and a basal like
breast cancer genetically engineered
mouse model and as we learned earlier
this is really important because obesity
across the span of premenopausal and
post-menopausal
contributes to basal like breast cancer
so we needed to look at that again we
use our same mouse model that resembled
human basal like breast cancer the c3
tag mouse
and here we did a diet switch study so
we had the mice that remain lean on 10
percent
mice were obese on the 60 and mice where
we induced a diet switch at 10 weeks of
age
again we observed tumor incidents and
looked at all the metabolic parameters
and tumor outcomes
so first we had to say did these mice
lose weight
so we were um
when we induced the diet switch at 10
weeks we indeed we indeed did see a
significant
weight loss and those mice parallel what
we saw in the 10
so they reduced weight all the way down
to the 10 levels so they reduce weight
to lean levels
same for fat mass so we looked at fat
mass again by mri
and we see that the mice in the gray
that were switched from the obesogenic
diet to the lean diet
these mice remain lean
and we saw that some of the metabolic
parameters associated with obesity and
also could be risk factors for breast
cancer the leptin adiponectin ratio was
completely restored when mice lost
weight
that was um at sacrifice
interestingly in this model we didn't
see changes in tumor latency um it might
be because these mice were exposed to
diet um
for a longer time this was nicer exposed
from weaning we didn't see changes in
tumor latency or tumor number but what
we did see significant differences then
is tumor progression so this is
showing tumor progression so when we
palpate the tumors we measure over time
for three weeks before we sacrifice so
we're able to measure two more
progression
so we see a percent change or a delta in
the tumor volume
so in the obese mice we see a
significant increase in tumor
progression that is completely lost when
the mice are
switched to
lose weight
switch diets to lose weight
some of the other meta metabolic
parameters associated with obesity we
measured our insulin
and then the homoscore we see that
insulin raises with obesity and was
restored with weight loss and same as a
measure of insulin resistance
and then i noted down here we didn't see
any systemic changes in cytokines
so the data i've showed you so far is
that when we did a longer diet study a
lifelong diet intervention
we showed that a decrease of obesity
with weight loss decreased vasolit's
cancer progression and now we wanted to
look at the role of hgfc met in that
pathway
so um the reason why we're really
interested in hdf is that hdfs have been
shown other models to be
um to be increased with obesity and then
this paper showed that when women had
gastric banding when they lost weight
hdf decreased in their serum so we were
excited to look um
in the micro environment so we focused
on the local microenvironment and breast
cancer
so when we first looked at the normal
memory and again we did immunistic
chemistry we saw increases in hgf and
cmet like we saw in our
first mouse model
and we saw significant decreases in hdf
and cement with weight loss
when we looked at the tumors we didn't
see dramatic changes regulated by diet
um in the tumors
in hdf but we saw again a significant
increase with
obesity in cement and a complete
reversal
with weight loss
so in summary we um saw that we could
reverse some of these findings that
obesity induced we saw
a reversal of obesity driven tumor
progression we saw a reversal of many of
the metabolic risk factors and
a reversal of the hdfc met pathway
so
we believe that htfc met pathway may
play an important role in vaseline
breast cancer
and so some of our future studies that
we recently got funded to perform were
to do some cement inhibitor treatment
studies
um
and also weight loss studies so um
one funded by the mary kay foundation is
to do cement inhibition
treatment so once these mice get tumors
we're treating with um a cement
inhibitor to induce tumor progression
and then we're also really interested in
prevention so can we
change or alter that micro environment
in obesity before the tumors
are detected so that's the cement
inhibitor prevention and that's funded
by an nci provocative question
and that's just ongoing
so and there's precedence for looking at
cement inhibitors because there's
several clinical trials
to look at
cement inhibitors in breast cancer and
also lung cancer
so to summarize our approach we
have focused on the obese
microenvironment and basal like breast
cancer so
we know that through epidemiologic
studies
that obesity and high fat diet can lead
to breast cancer risk but there's a lot
of mechanistic uncertainty
so we believe that by focusing on the
microenvironment and how obesity can
regulate that microenvironment
and using cross-species studies by using
human and animal studies we
can approach this in a broad manner to
find
risk factors that we can then address
and
so
we're really interested
in looking at weight loss because we
know that that's a modifiable risk
factor we can we can help or
advise people to lose weight and why are
we really interested in this there's
also a lot of health disparities
associated with breast cancer so if we
look at this
chart and look at
diagnosis and look at incidents
we know that african-american women
have lower incidence of breast cancer
but they have a higher mortality of
breast cancer
so
they'll also have a higher incidence of
obesity
they also retain more weight after
pregnancy
there's decreased breast feeding
and all of these could be risk factors
for breast cancer so if we looked again
at this carolina breast cancer study we
look at health disparities
that were revealed with carolina breast
cancer study and other studies between
african americans and let me just go
through this table so we see in the red
african americans and we see pre and
postmenopausal women compared to white
women that are again pre and
postmenopausal and the blue arrows are
highlighting the percentages so if we
look at luminal a compared to basal like
we see a much greater
prevalence of basal like breast cancer
in pre-menopausal women that are
african-american compared to
caucasian women and
post-menopausal african-american women
compared to
caucasian women so there's a higher
prevalence of basal-like breast cancer
in african-americans and especially
young african-americans
so
this gets to the other part of our grant
we um have community partners and we
partnered with the center for
environmental health and susceptibility
at unc as part of our grant
with the b cert program
and
in collaboration with
our bee surf group we also have a
community
advisory committee and we work on
outreach materials and
i'm going to show you a little bit about
what we've done there so what we're
hoping to do is translate some of our
findings in the lab through our
epidemiologic findings and findings in
our human studies with melissa truster
and our mouse findings in my lab into
humans so how do we
you know get this puzzle of individual
risk and population risk to help someone
understand their risk
so one thing we've done is a focus group
study and this is in collaboration with
um
marlin alicock misha graves kathleen
gray and melissa troster so um this is
something is a focus group study looking
at young african-american women and
their perspectives on breast cancer and
the findings were really shocking so
young african-american women perceived
breast cancer to be an older white
woman's disease
there was little to no knowledge of
subtypes
they wanted more relevant health
communications
and they we actually performed a second
focus group um with health care
providers and asked a lot of the same
questions and it was actually very
surprising to see
um that there wasn't a better knowledge
of the subtypes
in healthcare providers and that
manuscript is in
submitted in in preparation and
submitted
so um the last thing i want to talk
about
is
something that we've done is really
exciting and i hope that you all can go
to this website and i'm going to
push that to you right now
it should pop up on your screen
um so you don't need to look at it now
i'll just tell you about it and this is
a
it's it's a website to assess your risk
so
you can assess your health history diet
exercise
and the environment
environmental exposures and your health
screening
and then there's lots of videos to help
you understand risk and why we need to
advocate for more prevention not just
treatment
and this was something that was done in
collaboration with
the school for information and library
science
and so um
i
i am really excited to um be able to
present my data that included our mouse
models and also our outreach work and my
lab has been phenomenal in
all these studies and the one of the
main contributors is sneha syndrome a
postdoc in my lab who's now moving on
to work for usda
and
lots of other members in my lab trinley
and luma essay have contributed to our
manuscripts and now ongoing projects
are being undertaken by some doctoral
students yuan yuan and alissa so i hope
that in the future you can
see our follow-up studies on weight loss
and c-met inhibition
and i want to thank my collaborators
that i believe i think throughout the
talk including melissa troster chuck
peru
our close collaborators at unc the mouse
phase one phenotype unit david darr and
kat vent and then our outreach
collaborators who've been phenomenal in
um
helping conduct our focus groups and
doing our outreach work as well as all
the funding which is extremely important
to help conduct this research
and so
i just want to end by thanking everyone
and i'm going to
push to you again my website if this is
my personal lab website if you wanted to
learn more about my lab and
i can take some questions now we have
plenty of time because i must have
spoken very quickly
so i will
open the q a
um
and one
so one question is
does hormonal imbalance
trigger this effect
so um
interestingly so because
um basal like breast cancers are er
negative
usually estrogen does not contribute so
we wouldn't think that estrogen is um a
strong contributor to this type of
breast cancer however
some of our other collaborators have
shown that estrogen can play a role in
um
inflammation and so inflammation can
also be important in
breast cancer and basal like breast
cancer so there is some work about their
looking at estrogen and progesterone and
the induction of
inflammation by sandy hazma
and richard schwartz so you can look
into some of that
and um
second question
let me see i have to open this up okay
did
did you look for specific mutations
related to high-level hdf expression in
fat mice or in genes related to the hgf
pathway um i.e the ngs study so no
that's a really good question we haven't
um looked into
any mutations yet um one thing we have
we thought to look into was epigenetic
regulation because when we when we're
looking at our fibroblast study we were
really interested to see that when we
took out the fibroblasts from our obese
mice and especially the tumor associated
or the cats
they they secreted excess hgf and
induced more proliferation and more
migration even after being out of the
obese micro environment so that means
these fibroblasts were isolated frozen
thawed and then the experiments were
conducted and um
so interestingly they
they um appeared to have epigenetic
modifications because they they um
maintain that obese phenotype but um
we so first of all we are looking into
epigenetic modifications hdf is really
regulated in a complicated way because
it's um it needs to be cleaved to be
activated there's
hdf activator in hgfa and there's hdf
activator inhibitor hgfai so we're
looking at all those um
however our weight loss data suggests
that at least at the
whole tissue level which is where we did
our immunohistochemistry
is that um we don't see major changes i
mean sorry we did see major changes with
weight loss so we could
reverse the obesity-induced effects with
weight loss
but that doesn't mean
epigenetics might could still be
important
and
some of the mutations we haven't looked
at yet
um
um
i got a nice comment so thank you for
saying i had a nice presentation
and um
one of the last questions any role in
expression of fatty acid synthase and
basal breast cancer
so that's a really good question i don't
know the answer to that question um
i
i've contributed to other
other studies that looked at fatty acid
synthase and
lipid metabolism like in b cell lymphoma
but i don't know about basal like breast
cancer but um i could easily look into
that in my lab um that's a great
question
and
i believe
that's the end of the questions that
i can answer
so um someone has asked a question i
don't know the answer to so is luminal b
always her too positive or can it be her
too negative as well um i honestly don't
know the answer to that question i can
look it up and get back to you
um
possibly i don't know if i could email
you
i'm gonna mark it as to be answered so
why don't i email you after this is over
and um
and i'll get back to you on that
so
i think
that's the end of my questions and i
think i'd like to thank everybody for
attending and appreciate all the time
and
welcome your questions thanks a lot bye
you